ONE OF THEM ONLY FIVE TEAMS INN
>> GABE LOG CLEANS DOWN DEEP,
JUST 42 SECONDS
VERY, VERY INTERESTING THAT A S.
THE AVS HAVE S PLAY,
OVER THE TOP OF THE NET.
NOW CALGARY DOING A GREATWAY.
O'CONNOR IS ON HIS HORSE.
LOGAN O'CONNOR INTO THE CALGARY
>> CERTAINLY, CALGARY SCORERE.
TKACHUK FAR SIDE.
TOFFOLI HAD TO HUSTLE AND GET
AHOLD OF THAT ONED.
>> WELL, AS BAD AS THE POWERPLAY
WAS, THIS ONE AND A MILE
THE BEST PLAYER ON THE ICE FILM.
POKED AWAY.
MAKAR GETS IT BACK.UT
ESPECIALLY THIS LINE.
UP THROUGH THE MIDDLE.
SCORE.
GUDBRANSON FROM WAY DOWNTOWN
JOHNNY HOCKEY MOVES THE PUCK
ACROSS TO GUDBRANSON AND AV' ZO.
MONAHAN SWINGS IT TO THE FAR
SIDE.
WAITING AT THE
SEQUENCES YOU WILL SEE, A GREATG
SENT AHEAD, KADRI.
WORKS HIS WAY IN. OUT. THERE AVP
THE NUMBERS.
>>>>ECOND AVS. AWAY.
HERE' NATHAN MacKINNON INTO
THE FLAMES Z Z ASSIST, A COUPLEA
WONDERFUL PLAY.
>> RANTANEN TOOK A HIT FROM
FAR SIDE TOFFOLI.
BACKHANDER KICK SAVED GOT A LOT.
IT'S POUNDED OUT OF THEE JOB RIE
ND WE'RE GOING